doping and hooligans how dirty is
Russian sport that's our topic today on
quadriga
welcome it was a hard blow for Russian
athletes World Athletics governing body
the I double AF said that Russia's track
and field team should be excluded from
the Summer Olympics because of
widespread doping the International
Olympic Committee now says that some
modifications may be possible but it
looks like many Russian athletes may not
be going to Rio last week European
soccer authorities find the Russian
Football Union a hundred fifty thousand
euros in connection with violence by
Russian fans during a match against
England at Euro 2016 and now the ban on
Russian athletes some Russian sports
officials are suspected of encouraging
doping or at least covering it up many
Russians say the treatment is unfair and
they feel their country is being singled
out
so how widespread is doping in Russian
sports that's what we want to talk about
this week on quadriga
with three guests who are following the
story closely it's a pleasure to welcome
Ana Rosa she covers Germany for the
Russian newspaper Rossi skya Gazeta she
says collectively punishing all Russian
track-and-field athletes without
individual proof of guilt would be very
wrong and only deepens the divide
between Russia and the West
hi-oh zeppos is a reporter for the
German public broadcaster wdr and author
of an acclaimed German documentary
series on illicit doping he says the
doping crisis utterly discredit i'ts
discredits organized sport Russia is
certainly an egregious example but there
are other countries that are just lucky
no one's blown the whistle on them so
far and Alan Posner is with us he's a
political commentator for the newspaper
debate and he says doping corruption and
hooliganism are problems that go beyond
Russia the problem is that in Russia the
state is on the side of the criminal
so a warm welcome to all of you and a
cozy you say that a blanket ban is wrong
but the I double AFS decision was
unanimous and in fact it gave Russia
plenty of time to react Russia had six
months to clean up a clearly tainted
system of checks and balances now I know
that you were a runner in earlier years
you did also compete if you look back on
that time wouldn't you say that for an
athlete it is nearly impossible to go
into a race against others where you
don't know whether the entire system
that they're working within might in
fact tolerate doping I don't know that
there are plenty there is plenty time
before the Olympia that the olympian
committee has said that russian russia
is guilty of doping its Atlas assets I
think it's probably true that some of s
TLAs hairs taking topping but I think I
don't know that the this matter is very
profitable for this part for their
athletic or the world high support it
was your film in fact that exposed
doping corruption in Russia and thereby
triggered the idea double AF
investigation would you say the band
that we're now seeing is the right way
to get a grip on the problem I think if
a federation the Russian Federation is
obviously part of the system in terms of
cover above doping or supporting doping
then you don't have any other chance
because the credibility of the whole
Federation is failing so what could you
what you can do you cannot trust that
the athletes it's not the fault of the
athletes themselves it's a fault of the
Federation but what you can do if you
cannot guarantee a level playing field
at the Olympics so I think the only real
possible decision was to say we have to
suspend the Russian Federation which
means we have also to exclude Russian
athlete from the Olympics Alain Posner
the
International Olympic Committee itself
is not always exactly the most
upstanding organization around how fair
is it that it now turns on Russia after
having awarded Russia the Winter
Olympics in 2014 which now appear to
have also been a scene of massive doping
on Russia's part to what extent is the
IOC here somehow indirectly complicit
well that's uh it's a different question
for which you would have to have more
knowledge than I think any of us here
has I think it's the IOC it's known to
be corrupt in its up to its very highest
excellence they've admitted such I think
we need to look very carefully at the
awarding of our Olympic Games in the
past and in in the future I think we
need to ask ourselves a lot of questions
in that respect but not the question
whether you know oh you know we know
they are probably you know some of them
were corrupt we think the whole system
is probably more corrupt in it than it
then we know so therefore they can't
make any decisions on things which we
know about like doping which they have
found out which people like this is
eppela found out and proven this would
be just mean destroying your head at
your hands up in the air and say there's
no such thing as clean sport let them go
to it which is a position you can take
if you like but then it means that the
biggest criminals get the biggest prizes
that wouldn't be a very good outcome
which in fact takes me back to my
opening a question to Anna kozo whether
we can still talk about sport in the
presence of what is said to be
systematic doping let us take a brief
look at how widespread doping appears to
be in Russia let's hear what the IAW and
IWF had to say because the system in
Russia has been tainted by
doping from top level and down we cannot
trust that what we call and people might
call clean up its really are clean it's
a difficult task but the systematic
doping that has been ongoing in Russia
it's difficult to pick the clean up its
conditioning is proven you of course
that's unjust and unfair one of the
universally recognized principles of law
is that responsibility should always be
personified some members of your family
committed a crime should all family
members be held liable
including you personally animals that we
just heard there the statement by the I
double AF world athletics governing body
saying the system is tainted from the
top down in Russia and referring to a
very deep culture of tolerance for
doping would you say that's true and if
so do Russians simply see this in a way
that's different perhaps for many of us
in the West I haven't heard nothing
about the tolerance of a Russian state
toward a pink it's only information of
Western journalists and the question is
is the earth part system of the USA free
of doping is they are doping not so
spread as in Russia is the doping knows
so spread in China as in Russia it's
only one country that will be made
guilty and it's Russia because it's sort
of their mode probably it's on the time
to make Russia guilty is only one
country that can't answer probably how
you supposed you of course were among
those Western journalists that undergoes
adjust referred to as I said your film
your series put this matter on the
table and provided a lot of the evidence
that then was the basis for the
investigations your opening statement
said Russia was an egregious example
we've just heard Anna roses say Russia's
is being singled out and in fact
everybody does it
that's true that everybody does it but
the problem is to which extent and if
it's state supported at least that makes
a difference we had the same problem in
Germany 30 years ago East Germany a
really huge systematic doping
state-supported state-run system there's
no doubt and it has to be further up
that has to be done and now we have not
the same but a similar situation with
Russia and I think it's it's really
important to point the finger on that
and to say this cannot be accepted in
the world of sports if you want to have
a level playing field we have to single
out sports or countries we have to name
them otherwise the Olympics are tainted
and we will have results no one can
believe them and the problem is I she's
right when she's saying this also
happens in other countries but again the
difference is that it's not so huge it's
not so widespread and what is also
important mrs. Jose is that we don't
have we don't have proof if you have
proof you can work on it Russia supports
topic we talk about two different things
and we shouldn't distract arms effect
and I tell you clearly now that we don't
talk about state-run doping we talk
about it's a reason for the suspension
of the Russian Federation can I continue
please thank you and and it is clearly
said and proven because the world
anti-doping agency has all the evidence
every single proof checked yeah in full
length there's no doubt and for this
reason the Russian Federation has been
suspended only for this reason not
because of state-run doping because of
the proofs where they have and what I
don't know what we are discussing can
you give us a just a couple of examples
perhaps how you
from your film in regard to say the
complicity or active participation by
coaches or possibly also by political
officials for example coaches who have
been said that they are not working
anymore in the public domain not with
athletes working anymore even mr. Muto
is a Russian sports minister claimed in
an interview with me and Moscow a few
weeks ago said really the most in famous
coach and Russian Athletics racewalking
coach is not working anymore and we
could show that exactly the opposite is
true other coaches have been said oh
they are not working anymore we find
them both athletes in the forest
somewhere hidden in a forest excuse me
is they don't do what they promised to
do and what they pretend to do that
makes it complicated
I don't know this proves haven't been
proved from other organizations as
journalists and this is understatement
that you do now and it's it's not proved
yes it's proven because it's checked by
the IDF so what what is the matter what
can you answer when I say it has been
proven by the International at
acceleration just give me give me an
answer on that you do suggest this but
it's not proof that it's not efficient
for single out Russia in the competition
and so great competition is Olympics
it's it's only two cases that you have
investigated and single out from the
picture of Russia sports and when Posner
we've seen widespread doping for example
among cyclists in Europe and also in the
US are we ultimately talking here about
differences in degree rather than in
kind no I don't think so
though with cycling you might have a
point
what the what has been shown with
regards to Russia not only in athletics
but in football too now in weightlifting
we've seen it just today is that firstly
the the the the Federation which runs
the sports actively promotes doping but
this Federation is totally controlled by
the state and that the state uses the
results which the athletes gained
through unfair means in order to promote
its own setter so it's a circular thing
and if you know mr. Putin was saying
should you just be you know in a family
you don't all get punished if one person
as a black sheep he's right but the
point is that the main black sheep is
sitting at the top of the Russian said
it's it's mr. Putin himself who runs the
media whose cronies sit in the Sports
Minister at the same time the chief of
the Football Federation whose cronies
sit in all these federations and who use
what their athletes do it to further
their own ambition so this is why they
have to hit them because it's gonna hurt
them it's also gonna hurt the athletes
but it's not people like mrs. leopard in
Western media who are responsible for
that it's mister
it's the people who make the athletes do
these things who are responsible this is
not a fault of the athletes it's not you
shouldn't blame individuals you
shouldn't blame athletes we should blame
the people who are in charge of them
were supporting them were forcing them
to do that and to be honest I know that
from Germany I know that from East
Germany I've brought books about our met
documentaries about East German doping
system it was exactly the same athletes
have been forced by the coaches by
doctors to use forbidden substances this
is a crime you mentioned that there is
still some time until the Rio Olympics
the IOC is now saying there might be a
possibility for individual athletes from
the Russian track-and-field team to have
individual testing done and if they can
prove they're clean they still might be
able to compete does that go far enough
to remove what you see as scapegoating
and singling out Russia
yes it's enough I think so but probably
other sports men have prepared for
Olympics and they haven't taken topping
so much topping but the test had been
made has the man made two years ago half
a year ago and they are now clean and
nobody knows that they are clean and
they are excluded from this competition
and so I I don't think that it's
probably to take the tests in this short
period before the Olympics and prove if
they are really clean or not what do you
think how is that built is this a
workable solution or compromise that the
IOC has come up with and should at any
rate one person definitely be allowed to
compete namely the whistleblower who is
seen in your film
Yuliya Stepanova we have to make it very
clear here they don't talk about people
who can prove that they are clean it is
not correct because if you have a
tainted system then you have a problem
to believe people that are really clean
no positive test doesn't mean
automatically that you are clean in that
kind of system that is the first point
the second point is the idea we have set
and I always he confirmed that there's
under certain circumstances athletes who
are living up wrote were not part of the
Russian sports system and not right part
of the Russian doping control system for
years they can ask for eligibility for
the games in Rio
under certain circumstances as I said
and that is interesting that meets that
there might be a back door opened for
Yuliya Stepanova because she is living
approached she has all her testing in
the United States and in Germany she's
not part of the system anymore there
might be a kind of loophole or a
backdoor for her to get in but that is
one thing the other thing is if the IOC
whether
is he really wants that because just
imagine the political situation in in
Rio that you have in track and field
only one athlete under maybe a neutral
flag but on a Russian flag but a Russian
but the whole team is excluded all the
others that means from a political
perspective that is would be such
embarrassing moment for a further
Russian nation so I think the IOC wants
to wants to avoid that that's problem it
will be a problem so I'm not very
optimistic so far
Yuliya Stepanova will be allowed to
compete at the games meanwhile it was a
sports minister Vitaly Mutko
in Russia is saying that after the IOC
meeting in this week in Lausanne we will
do everything the IOC is asking what do
you think exactly that means given the
fact that this is the same sports
minister we saw in mr. Zeppelin's film
apparently covering up a positive doping
test by an athlete directly involved I
trust him
at the first and that the second I think
when they're Russian s let's all be
excluded from the Olympics it's great
lost for sport and it's great loss for
Olympic Committee and I don't know if
the American sportsman if the Chinese
sportsmen have not been doped and they
will be loved but you don't have about
this this is what you don't have a proof
you just claim I don't down yeah you say
there's your say this I'm very sorry you
say this no yes as I said they are
proofs they are proofs come on statement
let us take a brief look at another
issue which has also been tarnishing the
image of Russia's sportsmen and their
fans last week Russia was threatened
with exclusion from the European soccer
championships after Russian hooligans
turned violent before and during a match
in Marxist
here - there appear to be indications of
political contacts and complicity let's
take a look
violence on the streets of Marseille an
apparently spontaneous riot but some
British MPs claimed that the attacks by
Russian hooligans were by no means
random instead organised in advance with
financial and logistical support from
Russian politicians and sports officials
why were hooligans who were known to the
Russian police given permission to leave
the country and attend the tournament
why were they let on charter flights to
and from France without any police
interference afterwards the Deputy
Speaker of the Russian parliament
Igor leva dev tweeted well done lads
keep up the good work
he said these young men had defended
their country's honor
were the Russian hooligans directed by
state authorities and if so what was
Russia hoping to achieve
Ellen Posner let us think back to the
remarks by Vladimir poutine that we
heard a bit earlier in the program he
talked about the politicization of
sports and scapegoating of Russia the
fact is as you said in your opening
statement doping is widespread not only
in Russia so is hooliganism given the
fact that east-west tensions are quite
high at the moment and that we need
Russia to solve important international
issues like Iran like Syria is it
perhaps time to back down a bit on all
of the Russia bashing no one's bashing
Russia I didn't see your your the clip
we just said is bashing Russia yeah look
as a Brit talk hooliganism I mean you
know I'm not defending you know we have
a tarnished record ourselves Great
Britain but I don't think you ever saw a
British Cabinet minister Minister you
know responsible politician standing up
and saying well done let's use defended
Britain's honour it's always been this
is a disgrace there's been bans on
British hooligans attending matches and
so on from the British state so the
point is that hooliganism is the
principle of Russian politics and that's
why of course they feel that what the
what you know I mean I don't think
Russian hooligans in in in France are
worse than what mr. Putin is doing in
Ukraine to put quite frankly but if you
if you're if that's your idea of
politics that anything goes in the
interests of Greater Russia
then you know then how can the West deal
with that just say oh yes okay well put
that behind us here we can't we have to
call a spade a spade a hooligan a
hooligan and political aggression
political aggression what can we do
and it was among the hooligans who were
expelled from France was the head of
Russia's fan Association Alexander
sheesh Wigan sorry hard to say in the
90s he was a leading member of the
Russian neo-nazis scene he's known to
have extensive ties to Russian
politicians including the man we just
saw in that report the legislator Igor
the bed valve so clearly again a
political tolerance
least for hooliganism is it a proof
about that here is one netlist or I have
not understood that there he is known to
have ties with the neo-nazi scene in
Russia but what is it a proof of what a
proof that apparently there is political
complicity in the kind of hooliganism
that we saw and this Nets are seen in
Russia is political is it organized from
the state
yes sir the bed VF is in the legislature
he's in the Duma and he actually as we
saw in the report praised the hooligan
he's he's a member of one party is
Liberal Democratic or party it's very
Nationalist Party and it's not the state
and I would like to say that mmm
also Cameron David Cameron haven't said
I'm very pity and they were disappointed
of our English fans and nobody has said
Oh Cameron has not said that there he is
very disappointed of this events in
Marseille Putin has said that he is
disappointed is it not the lashing of
Russia he also seemed to have a certain
pride in the fact that only 200 Russian
hooligans were able to attack nearly
2,000 English fans it was a tonic
environment
what can we expect at the world soccer
champions chips that will be held in
2018 in Russia would you expect a lot of
fans to think twice about making the
trip and should FIFA perhaps be thinking
twice about whether the championship
should be held in Russia I don't think
that is the right step I think if there
is if there is legal proof force state
systemic interference in sports affairs
that means doping for us example then we
have to consider that but hooligans is
it that I agree with this mrs. Jose is
not a problem of Russia and you can be
hundred percent sure that in 2018 the
Russian authorities will do everything
to avoid any damage for Russia so I
think the problem wouldn't
not a big one 2018 thank you very much
to all of you for being with us today
and thanks to all of you out here for
tuning in see you soon